Every town across this incredible country
is someone's hometown.
And we're highlighting as many as we can,
like Boston, Massachusetts,
where attorney and mother of two, Anna Foster calls home
and get this, she created an organization
that helps budding female entrepreneurs
in her local area.
Take a look.
Hi Drew, it's Anna Foster
and I am standing in front of WBZ-TV
in my hometown of Boston.
I love Boston because it's rich in culture.
It's rich in community, and it's rich in innovation.
I want to show you around Boston.
So come with me Drew.
We're gonna have a great time.
Right now we're at the Seaport area of Boston
and right at the site of the Boston Tea Party.
I loved this area as I was growing up.
It didn't look exactly like this,
but as you can see, it's thriving and flourishing.
It has the water, it has the boats,
it has great restaurants and amazing small businesses.
Hope you can visit the Seaport area of Boston one day.
You'll love it.
So we're right here in City Hall Plaza
in the heart of Boston,
and I have a special guest with me.
Drum roll...
the mayor of Boston.
Mayor Kim Janey is right here standing next to me.
I'm so excited.
Mayor Janey, tell us about Boston
and why you love this city.
Anna, thank you so much,
and a shout out to everyone watching.
I love my city.
This is the city that I'm born and raised in.
I am a city girl.
Boston is a great world-class city,
a city of innovation, a city of firsts.
We are the birthplace of America,
the birthplace of public education.
First library, the best hospitals in the world,
the best universities, public space, beautiful parks,
and I'm just so grateful and honored to serve
as the first woman mayor, the first black mayor of Boston.
It is amazing.
Wonderful.
Thank you Madam Mayor Kim Janey.
Well Drew, that's a little bit
about my hometown of Boston.
I cannot wait for you to visit.
See you soon.
Thanks, Anna.
Boston is wicked cool.
I know, I'm sorry, I had to, but I really do love it.
I mean, I'll never forget the memories
of being with the Red Sox as
they broke the curse of the Bambino,
while we filmed a movie called Fever Pitch.
And don't even get me started
about Legal Sea Foods clam chowder.
Oh!
I'll see you soon, hopefully.
(theme music)